hi i'm georgina murros and i play
cayetano i'm miguel bernardo and i play
guffman on led
and today we're here with buzzfeed
taking a quiz to find out which
character reality we are let's see what
happens
so the first question is how would your
friends describe you
generous sneaky goofy
reliable honest or pity out of
all these options i would describe you
as
honest generous and reliable
i don't know which one the most maybe
you can choose i'll describe you as
generous reliable for sure very honest
you think you're goofy definitely i see
myself like a clown
all the time well which one would you
say you're the most generous reliable or
honest
reliable let's say i'm reliable as well
which former character would you trust
with a secret christian marina lu
of course she was my sister the only
person i think that i
really connected to when i was adopted
so i developed through the years a big
relationship of trust
carla because she knows how to keep a
secret so third question is
pick a class to study family relations
the art of backstabbing one two
three songs how to get away with murder
friend or foe the power of influence
101 they are amazing i love them yes if
you want to survive and helicopter you
need to take all of them how to get away
with mother
definitely because there's always a
mother next up
also we do that a lot for me as georgina
i say i
pick family relations i would love to
have that kind of
class in school me too family relations
goodman and miguel that's the thing we
both need to
to know more pick a new color for your
beautiful
teal pink purple brown
orange or black black is always a great
option
i usually dress up a lot with black but
i also love
purple i'm between those two for a
uniform
if i have to wear it every single day
probably black because
if not i would get bored of purple brown
which is a color that i really love
really brown doesn't look very good on
clothes well it depends on the person
you haven't seen my pictures in the
brown smoking smoke er
i don't know how to say anything that
sounds like i just said like i look
amazing in it no i didn't want to say
that the piece looks good
you were amazing with that next one pick
a superlative that best fits you
class clown best dressed biggest flirt
most athletic teachers pet or life of
the party
i think i know who you are i'm just
kidding
no i think most athletes if it's right
now i'll just go with life of the party
i want to be the class clown that was
what it was and georgina i would say uh
best dressed oh you think thank you
you're gonna
put best dress as well now choose a
musician to perform at your hospital
dojakat badbani jennifer lopez
maluma megan the stallion or drake
break 100 i know i knew that one i like
but bunny i like dancing his music but
also
i'm gonna go with lastly pikachin drama
to guest
star in riverdale euphoria stranger
things all-american
genie and georgia and sex education i'm
picking sex education i love it and i
love that they
talk about sex the way they do i love
comedy
i love sex education but i would choose
stranger things
oh my god
it says you are ambitious courageous
resourceful
like when you set your mind to something
you'll stop at nothing to achieve it
it's true i always say that in
interviews if there's one thing about
you you're not afraid to put in the work
when you approach situations you are
unconcerned with if the class is half
empty
or full but just that you always have a
class i like it i like it
cheers babe
you